[Music]
all right so I'm going to guess that we
can't solve the entire alright thing
right here but I think something we can
possibly solve is the media question
related to all of this because
mainstream media is absolutely crumbling
everyone knows it yeah when I was on
with you on election night what I kept
saying was we've watched the mainstream
media slowly crumble as the online media
has risen and I think as of the election
it's actually starting to tilt and now
the online guys are kind of winning
which is why you're seeing all the stuff
about fake news not to say that some
people online are pushing out fake news
I get that they are but what do you
think first of the of the meme of fake
news it seems pretty obvious to me
although I don't know the full
conspiracy behind it that someone in
power is pushing out this idea because
they lost control
yes conspiracy so much as somebody says
that there's one story that comes over a
fake news and everybody seizes on it
right which is usually how like being in
the right-wing media that's how it works
it's like it's a it's a you know it's a
shark scrum like it did the the Chum is
in the water all the Sharks come to
somebody says fake news they go ah
that's a great excuse for a Hillary
Clinton loss because everybody believed
all these fake things right now it's a
conspiracy of basically lazy people yeah
exactly that's exactly right exactly
right and I think that that it's that
again that's not to say there isn't such
a thing as fake news there is I mean
there are a lot of stupid headlines that
go around that are not true and that we
spend time to bunking you know from the
right and from the left things that
things that are just patently false
um and it's in Trump himself was a
rather large promulgator of things that
were false and it was important to try
and debunk those but the media had so
shredded its own credibility that it
couldn't fairly debunk any of this stuff
because they were saying things that
were false were true for years and then
along comes Trump and he basically runs
a post truth campaign so you have two
candidates running post truth campaigns
the media insisting that only one is
running a post truth campaign and then
everybody going wait a second like you
don't get to be the arbiters of truth
because you blew all your credibility a
long time ago well the problem is that
now no one's an arbiter for truth so the
media certainly wasn't so I'm glad to
see them come down yeah what I would
like to see take its place is okay now
it's honestly analyze what's true and
what's not true as opposed to what
serves our interest in what what doesn't
so the Washington Post called me
recently and they asked what if you're
trying to determine whether
news source is credible or not what are
sort of some quick keys and I said well
the easiest thing is are they open with
our bias and do they run stories that
counter their bias right if they're if
they're news outlet and they only run
left-wing stories and their left-wing
sites the only run left-wing stories
they never run a story that counters
anything that they say then you know you
should doubt you should double check for
sure
rather than they're probably just a
propaganda outlet but if they're a site
like I think the Washington Post
actually better than the New York Times
this way the New York Times is entirely
one perspective the Washington Post not
I'm not talking with their opinion
columnist I'm talking about the news the
daybreak like the Washington Post is
actually breaking some anti-hillary news
in the past in the in the last three
weeks before the election cycle so you
know I think it's important to
distinguish those but um yeah I mean
when there's no gatekeeper the good news
is there's no gatekeeper the bad news is
there's no gatekeeper yeah but it's not
full is a fully great thing because
nothing has emerged yet that act as a
that in it maybe that's just because
we're demanding more people but people
have to demand more of it I'm not saying
there should be somebody who like I'm
not the gatekeeper you're not they know
what the gatekeeper but I'm my own
gatekeeper right I analyzed the news for
myself
and I don't just believe every headline
that I see on Facebook yeah and that
that I do think is a concern because
that that's gonna polarize the news if
you're just picking the headlines that
reinforce your bias then you're in
you're not likely to to achieve anything
remotely resembling the truth and it
almost seems obvious that this is where
we were gonna duck because yep everyone
this is what everyone does on Twitter
you cater things to yourself I try not
to do that but every now and again
something gets to me to the point I
cannot follow this I mean BuzzFeed my
final straw I had on yellow them already
before that gains thing but I was like
wow that's why I'm followed this dribble
but but even that so there's a risk in
that yeah by slowly just filtering
everything into your own little idea
usually that the best indicators if
somebody's hated by both sides that's a
pretty good indicator that there at
least baseline honest yeah right that's
that's that's like that there's a level
of honesty and what I mean by that is is
not you know people who are obviously
conspiratorial but people who are
getting flack from every side because
they don't please one side all the time
that's it's not a foolproof test but
it's it's an okay test for people who
tend to be more honest yeah so you exist
sort of in both worlds you could you
consider yourself more more main
stream then no I do kind of straddle it
because you're on Fox a lot you're on
CNN a lot they should have me on that
often at because they because again I
have the Troublesome quality of not they
don't know I'm going to say it's a
little bit probably it's it's hard for
them a little right they'll have me on
like I'm on Fox News once every three
weeks maybe and I'm on CNN
once a month perhaps but I'm not like a
regular guest on any of these places so
if they continue to crumble even if the
online thing grows and as you're saying
when there's no gatekeeper or anyone's
in and this is a problem now okay as you
said it can be on us it can be on us
exactly
most people don't have some real risk
they're too well but people are lazy
right that's and that's and so that
laziness is going to apply except
there's not even a shred of gatekeeping
so that the problem with a lot of the
news that the problem of the fake news
critique is that it's encompassing a lot
of angles on the news so it's not that
the news itself is wrong its angles on
it's like how politifact does their
analyses so PolitiFact will say about
Mitt Romney will say sue this happened
during the campaign Hillary Clinton said
something about she liked open borders
Trump goes on stage and says Hillary
Clinton says she likes open borders
PolitiFact analyzes it gives it a half
true mm-hmm right and he's just
repeating exactly what she said they say
ah but his implication was that she was
saying x y&z right say well now that's
you're calling his stuff fake news but
you're the actual fake news because
you're reading implications that you're
reading into him once once you get into
reading other people's implications you
end up in some pretty dicey territory
but it used to be that when there was
actual fake news people lost their jobs
right like Jason Blair promulgated fake
news and lost his job at a publication
that we on the right hate the New York
Times but that's there's a difference
between that and the angle on the news
is wrong are the facts of the story
right and the angle is wrong that's not
fake news that you don't like the angle
on the story right in and so but the
left and the right should recognize this
not everything that comes from the
Washington Post or New York Times is
false
it may just be that the angle that
they're giving you is an angle that you
don't like or an angle that doesn't
reflect underlying truths but are the
facts of the story right
yeah the facts of the story right so in
the New York Times report something like
you know a when the New York Times
reports a the if they'd reported the
hands up don't shoot thing just straight
that's that's fake
if they report that a black guy was
killed by a white officer in Ferguson
Missouri and then they were proceed to
report it as though it's a serious
problem all across the country the fake
news part of that is their angle it's
not that a black guy was shot by the
white guy you know in in Ferguson
Missouri and what I've seen is that
people are throwing the baby out with
the bathwater so it turns out you can't
believe anything the media says right
now you can't believe their angle you
can't believe anything they say so if
they say Donald Trump hasn't turned over
his his IRS reports he isn't turned over
his tax returns there's a tendency from
people to say that's fake news and you
know that that's not fake news that's
true you may not think it matters you
may have 10 excuses why it's stupid but
that's not fake news per se when
everybody just calls stuff they disagree
with fake news and it's happening now
again on both sides you know I've never
felt simultaneously less bipartisan and
more bipartisan my wife and I have in
the recent past yeah but and again
that's where I think opportunity is
because there's so much being reset
right now what do you think about the
risk of it's not coming from the
government in some ways censorship right
now but we know what what's happened
with Prager you videos where they've yet
not restricted lists we've had I did an
interview with John McCain who is on
who's on cable news every single day and
there's a vent you decided to
demonetized it yeah I mean you know I
did my interview with ayaan Hirsi Ali
they demonetized we have all kinds of
stories now of things getting hurt
algorithms my even my low being banned I
get it Twitter can do what they want as
I said against the ban yeah so all of
this stuff is starting to add up to
something right yeah it that there's
something cracking down on this new Wild
West out yeah for sure and I think that
you've seen you know Twitter pay for
some of that in in market share yeah
it's going to be incumbent on people on
the right to build an alternative
structure to these things and that's
very expensive and people on the right
don't tend to think in terms of media
too much so we invest a lot of money in
politicians and we invest a lot money
and think tanks but we don't invest all
that much money in media there are a few
kind of people who will invest money in
media
yeah but the number of like we gave a
hundred million dollars to somebody to
start a business very low you'll see a
lot of people who spend like five to ten
million dollars to start something but
to start an actual Twitter you know that
that requires enormous expenditures of
capital yeah most people on the right
don't see that as a winning business
propositions people on the right tend to
think in terms of ROI and Twitter hasn't
even seen an ROI right
or Twitter is losing money still so it's
and and also it's it's hard to go up
against the behemoth like YouTube like
there's been some attempts to go up
against against YouTube before there was
a conservative attempt to go up against
YouTube it didn't do particularly well
because the problem is that it was
billed as the conservative attempt to go
up against YouTube it wasn't built as
open to everyone right and so you sort
of have to do the open to everybody
routine in order to really succeed but
you're at it you are at a systemic
disadvantage YouTube has existed for for
forever yeah but again YouTube is just
what the New York Times was thirty years
ago
the only thing in the space as things
progress I think that you're I mean the
truth is that YouTube is just a search
service with with a lot of big with a
lot of servers that provide space for
the videos mhm and I'm old enough to
remember when ask Jeeves was a and then
Google later so or hotmail I mean there
are the rile up prodigy that's probably
before your time exactly they're all
these things look insurmountable at the
time and then over time the market
destroys them right-eo L was the big
thing and now nobody used to say oh well
yeah I mean the thing is look this show
is on one of our our main method of
distribution is YouTube so I want
YouTube to work I want so do I want the
algorithm to work so alive anyway and I
think that it's it's it's a very
interesting debate I will say it's an
interesting debate when people look at
private companies like YouTube and they
say well they shouldn't ban anything and
it's like well you can make the argument
that YouTube should ban certain things
like a like a graphic terrorist video
for example should it do they have the
right to do that now for me I'd rather
err on the side of everything goes up
then think and then certain things come
down because I don't really trust people
in charge of anything to do that there's
why more libertarian even when it comes
to things like YouTube but I see the
argument I mean not all not all forms of
speech are created exactly equal least
in their merit yeah they are and they
are in terms of your right to say them
but they're not necessarily in terms of
merit and when you're in the private
sector you're speaking about Mary you're
not just term speaking in terms of right
to say yet do you think there could be a
First Amendment issue related to all
this now I get it the governor people
try to make utility's arguments
particularly good really because to me
it seemed it seems maybe not fully
because we don't know any hub like
utility but if there's something else
going on so it's not utilities but I
would argue that the owners of these
companies the people on the board you
know Jack
zuckerberg and all these people they are
so intertwined with our politicians
right now yeah that now we actually I'm
not saying it's directly a First
Amendment thing but there's something
there now I have it's almost collusion
with the NGO so I agree and in the
solution to that is to downsize the
government radically not to not to have
you know our guy do it right now that's
it that's that's what I'm that's what
I'm saying generally is like it's a it's
our guy doing it so it's okay now but
but yeah of course I think that
Zuckerberg working closely here's the
thing
Zuckerberg wouldn't be working with the
government if the government were
powerful right like if we spend a lot of
money on the government we give money to
political candidates we spend all of our
time talking about Trump or Hillary
because the government is powerful I
think anybody spent tons of time talking
like in 1836 about about the national
election I'm sure they spent some time
talking about if it wasn't dominant the
way that it is now yeah the idea that
people were just they could the most
important decisions people not dating
right destroying their lives because if
we won the presidency when it was
Franklin Pierce no not only no nobody
nobody was doing that is it and part of
the reason is that the federal
government just was not particularly
powerful so what do you care what some
bureaucrat in Washington DC's doing
doesn't affect you so that really I've
said a couple times to me that's the
best argument for small go yeah I agree
which is it wouldn't if you don't like
Hillary and you don't like Trump it's
not well then I should vote for more
Democrats or vote for more Republicans
people forget these idiots out of our
line exactly exactly and that's and
that's the I think the only smart thing
that Rick Perry said in his presidential
campaign in 2012 is he said we want to
make Washington DC insignificant in your
life like yeah that sounds great to me
because the answer anything else exactly
I said I said I say this on college
campuses all the time on college
campuses kids are constantly thinking oh
there's so many obstacles to what I want
to do and you see in politics now Trump
keep saying there's an obstacle to what
you want to do and on the Left Hillary
says there's an obstacle and I'll knock
down all obstacles we're all gonna knock
down all the obstacles and they erect
new obstacles right yeah and it's in
what I've always said is nobody gives a
crap about you like no one cares about
you no one sitting around going dave
rubin i got to stop that guy how do I
stop Dave look there's a couple people
there are they're a few down that's true
but but as a general matter if you
weren't even in politics if you're just
a guy right nobody will be sitting
around going how do I stop Dave Rubin
for becoming a successful accountant I
know nobody's doing that and
except that the government does do that
actually and so if we could apply that
same sentiment to the government like
nobody it's not somebody's business what
you do with your life leave me alone
solve your own problems right those
those few sentences in conjunction would
solve a lot of would solve a lot of
problems right solve your own problems
get the government out of your life
nobody cares about you except like you
and your family and your friends yeah I
know nobody's actively plotting against
you I know that we all live in our own
little movie and we do we all live in
our movie we're great villains and
you're the great hero and we're all like
this every human being is like this
which is why movies are successful but
in reality how many people in a lifetime
actually have active enemies who are
aquire attempting to thwart their every
move many people just have like the jerk
of a boss is bothering them right
although oddly in our space now for
public people the idea of the enemies is
growing all right yeah like now I get it
for the regular person you know it would
be nice to think right and we say
regular we don't mean like less I don't
not politics exactly I think people that
are probably doing but money that we are
but but the idea that you stake out a
position now publicly and you
immediately have enemies I mean I see
all the time now things will be written
about me that I know are absolutely not
true and they'll call me a far-right
winger and they'll call these things
what I've said about this or that and
they misquote me or any of this or a
partial quote and it's like I could
spend the rest of my life fighting this
stuff or I can ignore it and I usually
try to ignore it because I got a live
somewhat wrong and again it's [ __ ]
because these topics have become so
intense because there is so much control
over how these things go and also when
the government's very small everyone on
the everyone on the inside is a little
bit fascist what I mean by that is
everybody wants to be the king right
it's just you don't want anybody else to
be the king you wanna be the king you'll
be a good right you'll be the good king
you'll be the one person in human
history who's been an excellent
excellent king who is always generous
with power and decent with everybody
you're gonna be Daenerys Stormborn
you're just go around breaking chains
and everything's gonna be spectacular
right and that and so as politics when
politics was small that didn't matter
because the best that you could hope for
to be your own you know your fiefdom was
your house your fiefdom your home was
your kingdom your fiefdom was your
family right it was your those are the
people you were those were your subjects
and those were your citizens right those
were
people you took care of and now
government is so big that you actually
have a shot at being king when people
think they have a shot at being king or
at least getting into position a person
who's going to be the king for them then
you're an obstacle to their utopia right
it Trump if Trump is utopia and I'm not
voting for him I'm an obstacle to their
utopia if Hillary is utopia and she's
gonna be the great the great chain
breaker and I'm standing in her way then
I'm an obstacle to utopia right
everybody either becomes as I've said
before a tool or an obstacle to utopia
if you think the utopia is realizable on
a political level if you don't think
that then you're a fool like one of the
things that one of the things that I've
I think there certain areas where just
in life you become more mature as you
get older a little bit and you see more
of this and one is that when you're when
you're 18 or 19 or 20 your utopian you
think how do I solve this problem and
this problem won't be a problem ever
again and then you read more history and
you deal in politics more and you
realize there's never a problem that
actually goes away all the problems come
back yeah it's just a question of can
you push the ball a little bit this way
can you push a little bit this way in
favor of human liberty can you push it
can you can you push the looming
disaster a little bit further down the
road right is that in when you do that
you become an you become a problem for
people who want utopia because utopia
requires a lot of people to be willing
to sacrifice their present for a future
that doesn't exist hmm and that's that's
a scary thing I think everybody's a
little bit utopian now and that's that's
everyone's feeling that on both sides
right because you could argue that the
Trump people are feeling it didn't bring
all the jobs back to Ohio all of them
are coming back right he's gonna make
sure that we never have a terrorist
attack on American soil again and he's
gonna do it with his magic wand right
and he's going to do it by not trusting
the CIA or the FBI but still we'll get
it done somehow yet when we look we
should pause there for a second because
what what do you make that with it we're
just for one minute yeah everything
would rush I I know this is an example
where yes I think really no idea what to
believe so yes I think Russia hacked a
TNC
yeah I do I think that it exposed things
that were you see the evidence being
right okay some tense of it something
was legit right yeah I mean the
Democrats have basically acknowledged
that the contents of it were real they
weren't making things up so I think
Russia was behind the hacks
do I think that shaped the election not
really I think Hillary would have lost
anyway and the PI did a piece a few
minutes ago about this where I think
that the there's some evidence to that
effect
one is that Hillary's unfavorable
ratings in January of this year before
any of the WikiLeaks stuff happened her
favorable ratings were I think
43% favorable saris 38% favourable 56
percent unfavorable November fourth
through seventh right before the
election she was at 43% favorable
fifty-six percent unfavorable she did
not move at all right there was no point
where she built she was consistently
unpopular all the way across it wasn't
WikiLeaks made her unpopular the big
thing that hurt her in the last couple
of weeks was the Comey thing was the FBI
director saying the he was reopening the
investigation and that had nothing to do
with WikiLeaks that had to do with
anthony Weiner's computer so wasn't the
WikiLeaks that actually shifted things
right it was it was a lot of other
things but it wasn't the WikiLeaks
percent that said again this is a case
of shoe on the other foot
if the Russians had hacked the RNC and
Trump loses by 80,000 votes in three
states right are we crying bloggers or
be up in our right raise a plea would we
and would we be you know with people on
the right would be crying bloody murder
it'd be the end of the world yeah
again the hypocrisy on both sides is
pretty astonishing on the left going
although those evil evil evil Russians
they're so evil I hate the Russians in
2012 Obama was openly saying on caught
on microphone I want flexible and
inflexibility to Russia if they help me
out in this election so no no problem
which has fun in months of when Romney
said they're our biggest geopolitical
foe and everyone mocked him right and
also within months of hit of Obama
backing off the red line in Syria and
within two years of him backing off of
the Ukraine stuff right and and so they
didn't care about Russia four years ago
but now they care deeply about the
threat of Russian on the right the same
people going Russia's our major
geopolitical foe in 2012 I don't see the
problem oh I can't we be friends with
Putin no house this houses problems my
goodness I mean if you're if your
beliefs which that fast I'm gonna go
with you really had not a lot of core
yeah so to me because I can't really
figure out what the actual truth is I
don't think anyone really knows Intel so
right out of the question is you believe
the CIA and the FBI or do you believe
self-motivated people on both sides
right although right now it sounds like
the CIA and FBI aren't even in complete
agreement on what happened this is where
they're in agreement on they they both
do agree that the Russian sources were
behind the attacks
they just don't agree on what the motive
was right right so the FBI says it was
to undermine the election integrity and
the CIA says that it was to get trump
elected via given Trump's dated
positions on Putin which were incredibly
warm throughout the campaign I don't
find the CIA's claim implausible but
again their motives doesn't don't matter
bottom line is did they shift the
there's no evidence they did so the
reason I guess I'm a little more
skeptical is that if let's say we really
knew it was true at some level that this
was true Technic wouldn't that basically
be an act of war at this point if if
Obama knew right now he is EIA came to
him said this actually happened they
were in cahoots with Trump or whatever
it is it would be an act I mean when a
chlorine laying down sanctions or some
sort of military I mean that would that
would be a true undermining of our
democracy at the highest levels so the
fact that we're not talking about that
not that I want a war with Russia I
would be completely against all right
but the fact that it's not getting to
that level shows me that this seems like
more of a game or political showmanship
than something that's real I think it
also demonstrates a massive increase in
partisanship and the reason I say that
is because go back to 1972 and Richard
Nixon is bugging the the Watergate Hotel
in an attempt to get information about
McGovern right and he swamps McGovern
it's pretty clear that he didn't need to
bug the hotel in order to get the
information about McGovern to swamp him
ignorant ones like to States so and then
he's impeached by Republicans right
Republicans are getting he's not
technically he retires but he's about to
be impeached by Republicans Republicans
are going to impeach him for that now
you have a foreign power doing what
Nixon did right the exact same thing
they bugged the DNC right they that's
the allegation and nobody on the right
cares nobody on the right cares like
it's I don't think that has to do with
you know people aren't taking this
seriously I think that one of the
questions is just all right how happy
are you that they did it when the
question isn't and so I think there are
a lot of people on the right going well
it's good they did it I don't mind that
they did it I mean after all Hillary had
it coming I think that that so did
McGovern kind of in the sense that
govern was awful but that doesn't really
change the activity yeah well isn't the
other piece of this that if this all
happened who doesn't it show ineptitude
at the highest levels of our current
government I mean this not that Obama
himself would be making decisions
related to this but you'd have to fire
almost everyone at every Security
Service well and at the DNC right
everybody was responsible for the for
the security of the DNC yeah but who's
been government agencies apparently that
there there some hacking of government
agencies been going on for a while the
word cyber war with with China we have
been for a long time um yes I mean the
government as I've said Sox it virtually
everything
and the solution seems to be more
government from both sides now like the
era of small government is over the idea
that the government is going to shrink
in any margin in any measurable way I
think is fallacy so on the history
repeats itself for a long game idea
there is opportunity here right because
let it get big so that people will
ultimately see that it does not work and
then and then the error of small
government may become or yeah they can
get to a tipping point where you just
can't come back yeah I mean I do think
that you get to a tipping point it
sounded tipping point where you can't
come back because the tipping point we
actually hit disaster right at the Greek
tipping point yeah we're at a certain
point you must hit the austerity button
because otherwise your country is
absolutely bankrupt and then you get
riots in the streets and so the question
is how oddly are things when reality
sets in because the reality is you can't
keep affording to pay for all this stuff
eventually one of two things happens
either wise up or you go bankrupt like
California is about to do and things get
really ugly so it's so the question is
which one we head toward and the fact
that a lot of the gains it's sort of the
Buckley Reagan conservative small
government era have been put behind us
in favor of this bigger government
nationalist populism that's not a good
time that we're moving in in the wising
up direction it's actually a sign that
we're moving in the opposite that were
that were kind of now okay fine the
government's big we accept the
government's big what can the government
do for me today
yeah and that's that's that's a problem
and this is why like people were very
intense earning the campaign
conservatives saying Mike Pence Trump's
election isn't that great don't really
see a stick about the Pens peg
I was like yeah Mike Pence seems good
and then you've got my pencil now going
around to rallies with Donald Trump it's
free markets here saying that he's okay
with tariffs and saying the free market
fails when it's tried and from going
every time every time and it's a whoa
hold on that's bernisa coming from Trump
okay that Trump's been saying that stick
the whole time but like pence yeah
really at what point until we we as I
say we're not going to see you know
really where the Republican Party lies
until the first conflict between Trump
and the Republicans my guy there enough
Republicans who are gonna stand up
against him I don't I don't think so
either and I think the Trump is building
machine outside government in order to
take down the ones who do right he has
Kellyanne Conway building this this
apparently this machine it's gonna seek
to push his message outside government
maybe primary people who
grant him the leeway so it's such a sad
state of affairs because it's like we've
never needed a strong independent fourth
the state more than this that's right
that functions properly now and it's
exactly what we don't have yeah well
this is I've been saying this now for
several months and I was thinking during
the Obama era too is that it was clear
that the country is ready for a
demagogic fashion fistic leader because
they just want something done right
that's the fashion like people the word
fascism always brings to mind Nazis and
jackboots and all the stuff but the
truth is that most kind of most
dictatorial governments don't start off
that way most of them start off with we
have a breakdown in the political system
we need somebody to do something right
now right now there are too many
pressing problems get somebody in there
to fix it right now and if you look back
in history most dictatorial governments
don't start with the ultimately bad
dictator they start with a couple
educators who actually are not quite as
bad right if you look at like Germany
1932 1932 you're looking at it people
who actually aren't that bad right
looking at Bruning and you're looking at
von Papen you're looking a bunch of
people who who are like our people who
are like basically not terrible awful
human beings but they centralize all the
power here and then the next person who
sweeps in is the bad guy right so
whether you think that Obama was the bad
guy whether you think Trump is the bad
guy once you bring all the power to one
place once you've created once you forge
the ring of power then it's only a
matter of time before the bad guy gets a
hold of the ring of power unless you
destroy the ring of power because you'll
have a bunch of people who are seduced
by the ring of power
but eventually somebody bad will get a
hole eventually the Ring of Power will
make its way back to Sauron so you may
think that Trump isn't the guy who's the
threat which is fine maybe he isn't
you know I assume that he isn't because
I don't really see that he necessarily
is maybe you think Obama wasn't the guy
maybe you think that Obama wasn't the
true threat to American democracy and
liberalism but once you've got this much
power in one place somebody will be
somebody will be elected at some point
who just says screw all of the norms
things have to get done the trains have
to run on time right it's not only that
it may not be the guy you like it could
be someone it could be somebody really
that metaphor was pretty good but can
you get that into a Star Wars thing is
that possible can you get into some sort
I mean there's no the real good way to
destroy the dark side of the force right
yeah so in it
in in it's not quite as it's not quite
as good but everybody is everybody is
seducible like when you're a kid
everybody wants to be Darth Vader right
yeah when you're a kid nobody wants to
be Luke Skywalker everybody wants to be
Darth Vader it is much cooler you can
strangle people his mind right I mean
like he can really that it's much cooler
there's only one problem which is that
you also have to build this enormous
step starting blow up planets so
eventually a lot our to do something
though right I mean come on Alderaan
screw those guys
Lauren screw those guys terrible alright
one more for you Shapiro because I get
this tweeted at me a lot people say Dave
you should run for president in 2020 but
on the second part of the ticket Shapiro
number one you show people that bridges
can be built blah blah blah
would you ever go into politics um not
in California and and given the way that
our current politics is going it seems
like only celebrities can be elected so
where you'll have that part down I mean
you have your following that's yeah but
it would have be a lot larger following
than that right on there necessarily
that's it's it's something that that I
could see doing at some point you know
2020 is a little soon that's it it's but
I'm not averse to the idea of running
for office at some point but it depends
on whether you can do more good outside
of government or inside government
especially when you want to destroy the
instrument itself so not to destroy the
entirety of the government to destroy a
lot of the power of it and so it sort of
could never in a way you'd suffer from
although I know you don't telling the
truth a little bit Rand Paul on a lot of
stuff you suffer you'd suffer Anna
messing policy by the way I with a lot
of what Random House right but I but I
know in pharma and some other things but
you would suffer from the same thing
that he suffered from which is I'm the
out I'm trying to make this thing
smaller you're even if you're all
conservatives you're still trying to
make it bigger so the party can't really
rally around you because it doesn't
really fit the way people think yeah I
mean I think that to to benefit from
backlash politics you have to have as
you say there could come a point where
government is so big that people are
actually willing to hear a message of
solving your own problems screw the
government these people have destroyed
lives and power centralizing in one
place is not the answer but you know
people will have to be convinced of that
because until then everybody has the
everybody on the inside
wants that ring everybody inside wants
the the dark side of the force and so my
job right now is the same as yours which
is tell people the truth and hope that
they awaken to the fact that your life
is in your hands and if it's not in your
hands then we need to we need to change
the system so that it is in your hands
and people aren't taking things away
from you or promising you things because
a promise is just another way to take
something away from you sometimes it's
your actual your actual self control and
self esteem you somebody makes you a
promise to give you something and
they're taking something away from you
two nothing is nothing is free so if you
want to be totally self-sufficient then
we need an actual place that allows self
sufficiency nothing's free
I thought if you give someone gives you
something it's free you mean yeah it
turns out
yeah it's that inability to understand
that maybe screwing all of us is guilty
liberal exactly go all right what was a
pleasure talking to you is great great
to be here and are your office is not
that far from my new studio and it's
true so I suspect we'll be doing a lot
more of these crossovers I think we
could you know 2020 I just I really I
just could never be present I could be
vice president well today it's Chris job
I mean like yeah VP you just sit there
and you go to like a nice house and I'd
be Joe Biden yeah I am very good at that
I just I feel like you'd be much better
in terms of the n decision to that kind
of thing anyway for more on ben shapiro
follow him on the twitter at ben shapiro
I tried not to send him Nazi memes if
you could but again if you do if you do
all frame them put them on my wall you
know really just take pleasure in them
and enjoy them yeah and I know he won't
ban you for there you go that's true all
right
you
you